hey my name is Leticia Wright hi my name
is denoch Huerta I'm Mabel Cadena hi
guys I'm Alex avinali and we are here
today with BuzzFeed to find out which
character from wakanda we actually are
let's find out how do you react Under
Pressure Panic rationalize cry organize
school of friends loved one or ignore it
rationalize organize run away what is
that option
rationalize I would call a friend a
loved one pick a Marvel character for a
fun night out Valkyrie obviously whole
storm Spider-Man
Gamora or Iron Man Spider-Man for me oh
yeah he's fun Valkyrie hog is is really
fun listen I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna go
with Tony Stark you know throughout the
whole MCU this guy has nothing but fun I
want to have a fun night he's the go-to
man what is one of your personal
superpowers I'm honest I'm patient
optimistic I'm loyal empathetic I'm
open-minded I'm all of those things
I'm loyal I'm gonna agree with you I'm
loyal too you know our relationship
there's a loyalty to it to our people
I'm optimistic I'm open-minded pick a
scene from Black Panther that stood out
to you shuri fights killmonger Nakia
t'challa and akoya prepare to raise hell
at the casino killmonger and the child
during their final fight scene t'challa
and killmonger fight for the throne and
Baku leading the Jabari tribe in battle
Chala chases down Ulysses class tag I
like how calculated the Nakia t'challa
and Okoye scene was I really like that
casino scene but I love The Bravery of
shuri wow fighting killmonger I know
she's cutting up beating up her cousin
fight for the throne because I'm very
competitive
I'm on the motion about
I'm gonna go with
going the challenge and a quarter pair
to raise hell at the casino it's whole
plan of them coming together and taking
down this people okay now choose a song
to sing at karaoke cuff it by Beyonce
leave the door open easy on me
watermelon Sugar by Harry Styles about
damn time by lizzo no
My Bad Bunny because it's tropical it's
related to water and it's those kinds of
things that you know you start just
moving your hips no I'm going to choose
easy on me because I'm a dramatic girl I
really enjoy that side to Adele okay
I'll pick the Adele song
because it's in Spanish and it's easy
pick a Chadwick Boseman movie to watch
42 my range black bottom Marshall Get on
Up Avengers Infinity War fight Bloods
March I have not watched Marini yet
because that was his last performance
and I was pretty hard to to watch but I
think I would watch I would watch that
next because I've watched all of them oh
my rain is black bottom it's an amazing
movie I I could watch again and again
and again and again for sure I'm gonna
go with 42 because he broke the barriers
[Music]
this is funny your your result is
hilarious okay marazzo is Riri Williams
ironheart your personality matches Riri
like Riri you live by facts not opinions
you're super intelligent and treat each
day as an opportunity to learn something
new about yourself in the world you
thrive off doubt because you see it as
another chance to prove the naysayers
wrong you're self-assured resourceful
and independent I am quite independent
actually Riri is a dope character to get
who did you get sure
your personality matches shuri like Yuri
you're extremely Cleaver you're always
looking for new ways to improve yourself
and the lives of those around you you
are independent thinker which means you
often March to the beat of your own drum
the only thing bigger than your brain is
your heart she has a big hole you guys
are gonna see that in this film I think
you should screenshot that and save it
as your background uh I refresh the page
and I'm okoya number two
[Laughter]
create your own Natural Born leader of
course I'm I am love to challenge
yourself to see where you're capable of
and not to toot your own horn but your
talents just keep getting better and
better yes we are competitive listen you
keep rubbing in my face we all know that
you're great at holding your breath
underwater with six minutes and 30
seconds and anything will make it to
four no but you know I'm bragging about
her thanks for playing with us guys and
make sure November 11th wakanda forever
oh God
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]